thanks you guys that's very nice thank
you how you doing all right
good
good this is good you're out being out
is good
it is
I don't go out anymore I have a baby now
so I don't go out some of you have
babies but you don't love them so you're
here that's cool
no I mostly just go out with my daughter
I went uh to the park with her the other
day I was at this park in uh New York
City Park and they had these no drinking
signs at the park and it but it doesn't
say no drinking has a picture of like a
martini glass with a line through it
really the people causing the problems
with the drinking in the Parks
are they reaching their target audience
with a martini glass really
shouldn't it be like a bottle in a bag
with a line through it
you see people at this park at four in
the morning hey [__]
I try to go to movies but movies are all
[__] now they are they're all [__] like
they just have this machine that just
just makes [__]
I try to see I rented a movie I rented
the Jesus movie where they beat the [__]
out of Jesus for a couple hours wow they
kicked his ass what happened what did he
key somebody's Camaro what did the guy
do
look I didn't like the Jesus movie I
thought it was a shitty movie and it's
people get offended when you tell them
that like you're saying something wrong
it's like I thought that Jesus movie
sucked and they're like hey man like
what he's not in it who gives a [__]
like Jesus cares about Mel Gibson's
movie you know
look I was raised Catholic so I know he
did that for me and I appreciate it you
know thank you a little you should have
asked first you know I would have said
I'm all set I don't need that done
because
you're presumptuous only
I always raise Catholic and I'm not
anymore because they
they write I am [__] I'm going to hell
I am because I'm really about I do wrong
[__] a lot
man it's really I'm going to hell I know
it and I don't want to go to hell and
really because I don't like new places
that's really the reason
because I'm afraid I'll go to hell I
won't know where to sign up for [__]
I'll be all confused
like the first day of school you know
I wonder is there like a schedule to
hell how organized is your damnation
like the first they put you in one room
and some monster [__] you up the ass
for a thousand years
you come out you're like well I ain't
[__] around in there I tell you
I don't recommend that room
that was a drag
then they take in they put you in
another room and they [__] on your head
I don't know what the [__] they're doing
on there but what if what if hell's not
like that what if I'm just standing in a
hallway in hell like what do I do where
do I go
some Demon walked over me hey demon
and the Demon's like come on suck my
dick
now I'm blowing a demon in hell and it's
horrible
I'm thinking I shouldn't have lied so
much or whatever
but here's my question what if when I'm
done blowing the demon in the hallway
which how do you know when you're done
blowing a demon in the hallway
I guess when he comes fire ants on you
whatever
when I'm done blowing the demon in the
hallway
what if some guy in charge of Hall walks
up to me and goes hey man you didn't
have to blow that guy you know
he just hangs out here he's not part of
your damnation or anything
[Applause]
what did you blow him for
I I just assume you're supposed to blow
people
he said suck my dick so I you know
so say no what's so hard about that
Jesus
look man you better pace yourself you're
down here forever
you're gonna blow a lot of demons and
elephants all kinds of [__]
don't be freelancing in the hallways for
Christ's sakes
[Applause]
and also You Gotta Die to go to hell and
I don't want to die I like my life I'm
very happy I'm married and I love my
wife I love her very much my wife hates
me She [__] hates me she hates me so
much
like that's what she does like if you
ask her what'd you do today I [__]
hate that guy that's what I did today
I hate Louie
she's so mad at me all the time here's
the latest thing the other day she got
really mad she said to me you know what
you did you filled the dishwasher with
dishes you put the soap in and you
didn't turn it on
and I'm like oh [__]
what are we gonna do now
but here's the part where she blows my
mind this is amazing when she gets to
this level she says well why didn't you
turn it on
like I have a reason for not turning it
on
and I'm like can't I just be stupid
can it just be that I'm a [__] idiot
that I filled the dishwasher and then I
went boo and I walked away
I can live with that I'm cool with that
but she says no why'd you do it which
means I decided not to do it do you know
how much more of an [__] that makes
me
that means I fill the dishwasher and
then I went you know what [__] her I
ain't turning it on
she can suck my dick if she thinks I'm
pressing that on button I'll fill it but
I don't [__] press on not in my own
house why would I do that
that would be crazy
the thing that she's usually mad about
is simple she says that I don't listen
to her when she's talking
and I don't but
it's not because I don't love her blah
blah it's because
I try to listen I really do when she
talks I just stare at her face I'm like
come on bring the story
but somehow I'm like what the [__] I
can't do it I try
because every story
he gets crazy and I'm like holy [__]
I've got add I can't do it on my [__]
please
but I try every time I try because I
love this [__] woman so I try really
hard
to listen to her stories
other people don't even try we go to
parties she starts talking people just
walk away like [__] this that lady's
crazy
who would waste time listening to that
crap me
she can't help it I really feel bad
because the thing is that every word of
the story gets her so excited that she
wants to [__] run with it
she can't [__] just break through and
get to the end or even the beginning
this is my wife telling a story she's
like guess what happened to my mom today
I'll stop you remember I told you my mom
how she when she was in college not when
she went to Michigan when she
transferred remember because that guy
got weird and she had to leave because
he was not the Iranian guy that was a
different story that guy I actually I
think he was Persian I heard that Persia
actually split what the [__] are you
talking about
sis Christ
pick a thing
have some consideration for the [__]
listener
I don't do that here's me telling a
story I bought a tomato and I ate it and
it was good
a story anyone can follow it's about a
tomato the whole time
I like being married do I do I really
like it I seriously do we were having
sex with my wife and I a couple weeks
ago which is amazing that we did that
because
we never have sex never because we have
a baby and our baby's a [__] [__]
won't let us have sex
kind of [__] that kid's a jerk man
seriously every time she's got some
urgent [__] in her room Papa come in
here wait a minute now okay I go in
there what's up I need a pair of pants
to put on my pony
wow holy [__]
I'm trying to [__] your mom in there
would you give me a break
can a guy [__] your mom for a minute
[Applause]
there is no sex man I had no idea that
marriage just means no sex no none
[__] none
I have friends that are thinking of
getting married and they say funny [__]
like hey you know I don't know if I
could do it because I don't know if I
could have sex with one woman for the
rest of my life like don't worry about
that [__]
[Applause]
you're gonna have sex with zero women
for the rest of your life that's a lot
less than one
one woman who the [__] you think you are
where'd you get that fantasy
I'd love to have sex with one woman for
the rest of my life any one woman big
fat dead lady with a beard I'd [__] her
every day
I'd be proud to have her
that's not usually my problem these days
my problem is very simple it's trying to
find a place in my house where I can
masturbate without somebody bothering me
and that's really difficult
there's nowhere to go anymore she's got
her mother staying with us too in the
guest room and I'm on the streets now I
got nowhere to go
a guy on the West Side Highway jerking
off and playing daylight that's not a
homeless guy that's a married man right
there
he's got nowhere to go [__] it [__] you
dude
it's not fair man I'm 37 and I own my
home I should be able to just stand in
the living room how you doing honey good
morning
[Applause]
but I can't I gotta hide I'm down in the
cellar by the boiler like a troll down
there
[Applause]
just [__] miserable oh [__]
that's what it's like masturbation
doesn't bring much joy to guys women
seem to like masturbating they put
flower petals on the pillow they're like
oh me or whatever you know
[Applause]
my guys looking on [__]
God damn it
sometimes you find Ecstasy but it's
followed by the deepest self-hate and
depression you've ever felt it's an
amazing drop from way up here to this
like oh yeah what the [__] is wrong with
me God damn it
thank you
I gotta get to work I don't have time
for this [__] right now
[Applause]
but then you get married now you gotta
hide and you have to you have to hide
because when your wife catches you
masturbating that that's sad for the
whole family that's not
a good moment in a marriage
she comes in the cellar oh my God
and then she always wants to know [__]
about it he always asks me stuff my
wife's like well do you think about me
when you're doing that
what are you [__] high why would I do
that
I can think about anybody that's magical
[__] what I am married to you what do
women really think their husbands are
going oh my wife oh yeah that's [__]
hot oh yeah
picking her up at the airport getting
yelled at all that's [__] hot yeah
put it in the hamper not on top you
idiot oh I love when she talks like that
yeah
but uh you know whatever
we're a family we have a kid that
changes everything that's the whole
thing the kid is everything marriage is
nothing without a kid marriage is dating
it doesn't mean [__] and you don't
realize until you have a kid here's what
happens when you get married you go holy
[__] I can't leave now I mean I wasn't
thinking of leaving but now I really
can't leave then you have a kid and you
go holy [__] I could have left
[Applause]
I totally could have left [__] door
was right there now I can't go
I got a kid now
I love my daughter it's a lot of
responsibility that you never think
about though like uh you gotta name your
kid that's a big deal right there you
know what's amazing to me you can name
your kid anything you want
isn't that incredible there are no laws
there should be a couple of laws
none you can literally name your kid
anything you can name your kid a name
with no vowels if you want like
oh
just 40 F's that's his name
go clean your room
[Applause]
some people name their kids a word like
sunshine or battery or whatever
I'd like to name my kid a whole phrase
you know something like ladies and
gentlemen that would be a cool name
this is my son ladies and gentlemen
then when he gets out of hand I get to
go ladies and Gentlemen please
[Applause]
but you got to be careful what you name
your kid you have to be careful because
what happens is other kids in school are
going to make fun of them they're going
to make fun of their name and you don't
have to give them a weird name because
they can do it with any name kids are
geniuses at that
any name they take it they go Louis
screwy Joey blowy Mike your mother's a
dyke whatever they find a way these kids
any name with it what's your name Eric
you [__] [__] see just like that
lightning speed these kids got
what's your name
Joe eat a bag of [__] [__] face you see
just like that
he got that all through school and cried
like a [__] it's not gonna happen
to my little girl
my daughter is really something else man
she's she runs the house she runs the
whole house she decides everything like
we were playing hide and seek the other
day we play hide and seek and we play by
her rules that she invented
and do you know why because she sucks at
hide and seek
and so she covers it with his [__]
roots to level the playing fields and I
gotta [__] pretend it's all that
she's great
no it's [__] like we're playing
oh [__]
I know she's a kid but [__] listen
[Applause]
when it's my turn to hide she tells me
where to hide
she tells me where
she goes hide in the closet Papa but
you're gonna know where I can hide the
closet all right [__] I'll hide in the
closet good fine
now I'm just standing in the closet like
an [__]
she comes in I found you she's like
shitty about it like I found you and I'm
like wow
how did you figure out where you told me
to [__] hide
and then when she hides this is her
hiding she goes over to a wall and does
this she goes
like this is some Ninja invisibility
Crouch
and I gotta act like an idiot I can't
just walk in and go yeah you're there
because she'll cry and [__] her pants
right
so I gotta walk around like an [__]
where is she I have no idea
where could she be
I'm making eye contact I don't see her
it's amazing to me
the other day we're playing this is how
things have got in my house okay here's
a very good example of where it's gone
we're playing a version of hide and seek
where my wife and I have to decide
together where to look she likes that
she's like Mama you tell Papa where to
look okay fine so she's over there
hiding like this just in plain sight and
my wife and I my wife's like why don't
you look under the bed I'm like okay
she's not there
then she says why don't you look in the
linen closet okay so I open the closet
she goes that's not the linen closet we
don't put that in there anymore all
right [__] Jesus all right okay
so I look at it why would she be in that
closet has shelves she can't stand in a
shelf well maybe she's crawled in a shut
now we're having a fight about where to
look for this [__] kid who's standing
right there
let's go
[Music]
it totally runs the house I remember
Halloween last year a couple days before
Halloween my wife comes up to me and
she's like we have to get you a cat
costume
no no we don't actually
no we do because she thinks you're a cat
I don't know it's like she's got a she's
a guy with a gun in the other room
that's what it's like
thinks you're gonna be a cat
I don't know how she got it in her head
but she's expecting to be a cat on
Halloween
let's go tell her to go [__] herself
because I'm not doing it
I'm not afraid of her
she's two I'll [__] fight her I could
take her
I could beat the [__] out of thousands
of two-year-olds all day just walk
around
they would never even gang up on me they
suck I'm not afraid of her
so my wife decided that she wanted to
get pregnant again
she decided it
and this is back in August she told me
uh you need to be in town next week
why because I'm getting you know
modulating so like not do you want
another kid just be in town that's how
she handles it
I'm like I'm not gonna I don't want
another kid so [__] she's like all
right next week she starts blowing me
right now she hasn't blown me in Jesus I
don't know if I've ever been blown
that's how long it is
she's blowing me on the day she's
ovulating I'm a [__] idiot I'm like
yeah you love it like I think she digs
me now
[Applause]
Prince stupid
so she's having another baby any day now
she's due and uh it's true
the whole thing I'm like
[Music]
hey no no it's great
[__] it that's really the attitude that
keeps a family together it's not we love
each of this [__] it man [__] it
[__] it
another kid [__] it why not let them all
in good
[__] it
but the problem is
money I don't know where she thinks the
money's coming from we're so broke I'm
so sick of being broke I'm broke all I'm
just always just keep digging this whole
and most people are broke too that's the
thing this country's just everybody's
broke that's why I don't look I don't
like George Bush but I didn't like
Carrie either because they're [__]
both rich and they don't get it they
don't know what it's like to be poor let
poor people know what it's like to be
rich they know exactly what it's like
because they fantasize about it
constantly
every poor person has their whole rich
life all planned out
every detail I'm gonna have a house made
of chocolate and
people are gonna blow me as I walk in
each room they're gonna be waiting
I'm gonna wipe my ass with live rabbits
and throw them out the window
got it all worked out
but rich people don't fantasize about
being poor why the [__] would they do
that I'll have to take the bus
everywhere yeah
I've always been poor my whole life I've
[__] never had any money and I know I
don't care I don't give a [__] but you
know there's a lot of people that are
poor now like I was driving through
Upstate New York and there's people up
there man their lives are just shitty
like you ever drive through a whole town
and you're like what did a [__] bomb go
off in this place what happened
everybody's life sucks in the whole town
and you can tell because they're just
standing in front of their houses like
laughs
is it bleak
and a lot of people call those people
white trash and
I love that expression white trash
because it's the only racial expression
that you can use and nobody gets
offended nobody gives a [__]
when you say white trash nobody goes hey
don't talk like that about them that's
not nice
nobody defends white trash
you could be talking to the most liberal
hippie in the world your head I saw this
guy he was white trash he'll go [__]
that guy
white trash loser
I don't know I just want to be a good
dad raise my daughter and
it's a complicated country people get
angry they don't everybody hates gay
people I never understood anger towards
gay people because a person being gay
doesn't affect your life so it's weird
to me that people just like they're in
their homes going oh people are gay
damn it
what do you care I could understand
hating gay people have say like you're
mowing your lawn and two guys are
blowing each other right on the grass oh
I gotta cut around you [__] every
Sunday I'm sick of this [__]
or say you're eating your breakfast in
the morning and you're about to put your
spoon in the cereal bowl and two guys
touch dicks right in front of you hey
come on
I gotta get to work I don't have time to
dodge your dicks with my spoon
[__] homos get out of my kitchen
I hope I'm a better parent than my
parents were my parents were not good
parents
my parents here's a typical example my
parents this is a true story I swear to
God my parents sent me to summer camp
when I was in third grade it's a good
idea right but they didn't look into the
camps they just chose one out of the
phone book randomly
and I swear to God this happened
I get there it's a camp for all [__]
kids
I swear to God
I went to camp for [__] kids
I swear to God I'll never forget the
moment I arrived I looked around and I
realized holy [__]
I'm [__]
[Applause]
I didn't think I was but I must be
am I the only kid who's not
this is how they chose to tell me this
is it
just send them to the camp [__] it he'll
figure it out
he's [__] he's not stupid
I loved it there it was great
everybody's nice every game is a tie
just gold medals for everybody it was
awesome
here's the thing I never never never
judge other parents now I never do I
used to but I never do like you know
when you see a mother in McDonald's or
someplace or in a toy store and she's
just melting down on her kid she's like
shut up I hate you you're ugly
and people are standing around going oh
my goodness she's a horrible mother
well guess what those people aren't
[__] parents they don't have kids
because any parents who are in that
store thinking what did that shitty kid
do to that poor woman
[Applause]
that poor woman I wish I could help
because you don't know man you don't
know
or like when you see a parent that seems
to be negligent like you're in you'd see
a parent in McDonald's with the kid and
the parents are like I can't take this
[__] anymore and just like collapsed and
all the shopping bags are just strewn
everywhere and the kid's happy the kids
eating french fries and the kid asks a
question like Mama why is the sky blue
and she's like just shut up and eat your
French fries
and you think what a terrible mother why
doesn't she answer her child when I have
a child I will answer all of their
questions
and open their minds to the wonders of
the world
well guess what you don't know what the
[__] you're talking about
you can't answer a kid's question they
don't accept any answer a kid never goes
oh thanks I get it they [__] never
say that
they just keep coming more questions why
why why so you don't even know who the
[__] you are anymore at the end of the
conversation it's an insane
deconstruction it's amazing this is my
daughter the other day she's like Papa
why can't we go outside well because
it's raining why
well water's coming out of the sky
why
because it was in a cloud
well
clouds form when there's vapor
why
I don't know
I don't know that's I don't know any
more things those are all the things I
know
why
because I'm stupid okay I'm stupid
why well because I didn't pay attention
in school okay I went to school but I
didn't listen in class why because I was
high all the time I smoked too much pots
[Applause]
why because my parents gave me no
guidance they didn't give a [__] why
because they [__] in a car and had me
and they resented me for taking their
youth
why because they had bad morals they
just had no Compass why because they had
shitty parents it just keeps going like
that why because [__] it we're alone in
the universe nobody gives a [__] about
us
I'm gonna stop here to be polite to you
for a second but this goes on for hours
and hours and it gets so weird and
Abstract at the end it's like why well
because some things are and some things
are not
why well because things that are not
can't be
why because then nothing wouldn't be you
can't have [__] nothing isn't
everything is
why because if nothing wasn't there'd be
[__] all kinds of [__] that we don't
like giant ants with top hats dancing
around but there's no room for all that
[__] why I'll [__] you eat your French
fries you little [__] God damn it
thank you very much everybody good night
thank you